have you uh
like
done a lot of hard drugs
not as much as i think people think i've
done i'm not really into drugs like i'm
really just into what makes me feel
balance you know like
normal i guess or as normal as i can get
well well i mean what kind of drugs have
you done like i i've done molly before
i've done bad molly and that was enough
to never make me want to do it again
like once you do the bad version of the
drug you think you're doing normally
that would make you want to stop well
for me it makes me never want to do it
again yeah that's an issue i never asked
you about you ever done a drug where
you're like oh [ __ ] i shouldn't have
done that or you were just like yes like
when i drank aluminum cleaner oh my god
what i think that's what it was that i
got it was some like aluminum cleaner
[ __ ] and i [ __ ] couldn't get off the
kitchen floor like well because you told
me about a time when you were in new
york and you just felt like you were
free-falling and like
i was in london england that was on
ketamine that sounds
horrible i friendly would do that in
college and just do it in their dorm
rooms
it was it was the greatest ever you're
snorting ketamine and allison you're
done snorting and you're like
i'm just like so
utterly [ __ ] up on ketamine that the
hotel room i was in
just started free falling and like i i
was like
looked up and it was like the i i was
looking up at like a shaft that it was
falling through
it was the greatest thing that ever
happened while that was happening you
were like [ __ ] yes i was like this is
the raddest [ __ ] thing i would have
freaked dude that stuff scares me i
think cause like i think because i was
forced to take
pills
growing as a kid there's never i'm i
don't have that desire so much to do
drug like there's i don't i don't really
do that many drugs like i've done coke
i've done
once
you know i've done mushrooms here and
there
but i really just like weed
lsd
no molly that was it all right heroin no
no never never had the urge i think that
clip was awesome but not as awesome as
my new book a hard kick in the nuts what
i've learned from a lifetime of terrible
decisions which is out september 27th
and if you pre-order it right now
you can get the autographed copy so
get on it man pre-order my book it's not
going to waste your time because i'm
proven dude new york times bestseller my
first book's 5 star rated on amazon and
i have no doubt this one will be two so
get the autographed copy right now
by pre-ordering it at stevo.com
yeah dude